far cry 5 would probably vote Trump it
likes billion billions and billions and
billions and billions this is versus the
GameSpot show that pits your favorite
games consoles franchises and hot-button
issues against each other this week the
Battle of the farc rise as we pick new
boy far cry 5 against its great-great
grandpa bark right to fighting for five
is two more Hussein who despite spending
hours playing with boomer in the game
and even meeting him in real life is
still very much a cat person and making
the case of far cry 2 is Oscar Deus who
upsettingly was only 12 when the game
actually came out in 2008 regardless of
his short time on the planet he still
insists that far cry 2 has never been
bettered each are going to argue the
corner for their game over the course of
three randomly picked topics with the
overall winner being decided by you the
wonderful viewers despite an excellent
argument from me last week's tense
debate on console exclusives so oscar
notch up a second win with a staggering
85% of you voting for ps4 can we please
stop letting him win anyway we're going
to be throwing up a clickable poll right
here on YouTube or if you're watching
over on GameSpot calm let us know who
you think has won the debate in the
comment section below right let's get
into it
[Music]
well Oscar I'm gonna set fire to this
table and it's gonna burn you you know
what I've noticed over the last few
episodes of vs. what's that somehow my
man has got the easy wins right yeah cuz
I'm really good at that bacon did the
free wins three wins for this guy three
wins it's actually two wins but that
today is someone in the back rigging
this for you it's your mum isn't it
right she died yeah I'll pick the first
one
exploration and emergent gameplay well
far cry 2 I think is pretty obvious that
it has the better exploration and better
stories come out of its immersion
gameplay as well and I think a lot of
that comes down to its mechanics which
at the time not everyone loved they had
the rusty guns and the malaria and
particularly the guns they force you to
explore because when your gun goes wrong
it forces you to go and pick up an
enemy's gun right
and it's the same with its mechanics in
terms of the map it is a really good
example of why I think Far Cry 2 is
better than Far Cry 5 as a whole in the
in Far Cry 5 you press the button the
map screen comes up in Far Cry 2 you
press the button and your character
holds up a physical map in the game and
you have a GPS device on your dashboard
in your car holding it in front of your
face like that forces you to actually
look at the map whilst you're still
driving and so then you can like crash
into a zebra and then your car explodes
every part of the game is feeding into
the fact that it's forcing you to go out
and explore the environment you can't
just get by and go wherever you want
with loads of fast travel points
everywhere so I agree with you however
my big bug bear with Far Cry 2 is the
moments are kind of punctuated amongst
huge stretches of frustration as well
every time you get one of those emerging
gameplay moments or you are exploring it
also comes with the risk of something
utterly destroying your fun what is
great about Far Cry 5 is it takes those
ideas from Far Cry 2 and it kind of
refines them because it means it kind of
drags everything together and kind of
streamlines the the kind of emergent
moments you have without making you feel
like you're also on the cusp of having
your play session ruin
by something like malaria or for example
let's look at the idea of using a map
while you're driving that's a great cool
thing it also means that there is a
chance that you could crash into
something your car blows up you're in
the middle of nowhere you've got malaria
what I like about Far Cry 5 is you've
got the map but what it makes of what it
does is it Charlotte not challenges you
but invites you not to look too much at
that map it's just like go around and
whatever you stumble upon is a moment
for you you get those same emergent
moments but you feel in control a little
more so that means that you can get more
rewarding experiences out of it without
feeling like you're being punished by
the game I agree that far cry 5 is a
smoother experience overall and
definitely has refined the sort of
formula but it's those frustrating
moments those small frustrating moments
where your gun does explode in front of
your very eyes or you have malaria or
your gun your car breaks down that make
the successes in Far Cry 2 so special
randomness is what keeps you on your
toes
you're so adapt and then when you do
succeed you're like I earned this
success rather than in far cry 5 it's
like you're given all of you five high
five is like a drug it's like you're
given this steady supply of heroin or
cocaine it makes you feel good and it
makes you feel like the top of the world
do you feel great
how often as long as you keep jamming
that never stop don't stop taking heroin
ever
next one is gunplay or as I like to call
it in the context of Far Cry 5 fun play
well delete yourself slow zoom ok wise
again I think I think no I think it's
good like there's the base level thing
where every gun feels good every weapon
you use feels good I love stylish
weapons I love the bow and arrow the bow
and arrow is so cool in the Far Cry 5
it's silent y'all know me
same old silent G what's great about it
is like you can't carry too many arrows
so you've got to go up and pick those
hours back up to basically give you a
good stock of them constantly and that
means that the strategic considerations
it introduces to wiping out a camp is
twofold now not only have you got to
think about killing an enemy you've got
to think about I also need to go to that
enemy's body and pick up the arrow just
in case and that makes it more fun for
me as someone who likes considered like
slow methodical movement through areas
as part of like stealth then you've got
like other things like you know rocket
launchers you know ridiculous grenades
and all of that has an impact on the
world and the way it changes like I like
the idea like throwing a grenade into a
camp and just running away and watching
what happens and seeing it all kind of
tear itself apart or spook and animal
and and the animals kind of attack you
attack the enemies that you're up
against like that's what I love about it
like freedom to do what you want all
accessible from the outset supporting
the type of gameplay you want always
making it fun interacting with the rest
of the world and kind of bringing the
fun to you I think a lot of that is true
but I think Far Cry 2 sort of does a lot
of what you just said in a similar way
but in a much more natural way Jarman
Jarman and some of that is the weapon
jamming which like is an actual thing
that happens in real life and I really
like that attention to detail and how it
forces you to go out there and find
other weapons and experiment with
different types of gameplay but also Far
Cry 2 has an amazing attention to detail
so like one of my favorite parts of Far
Cry 2 is like if you shoot an enemy in
the
foot he won't die he'll limp to cover
try and recover there and then maybe get
a friend to come and help him and lift
him out of danger that's a a that's not
gunplay yeah but that's but that's part
that feeds into the gunplay you know you
cuz in five by five you shoot them and
then they're just they either die from a
shot in the foot which would now they
they behave similarly like if you shoot
them in different parts they don't just
instantly all they're good or they go
down with like an icon over the head
being like revive me and it's like is so
artificial and it the same thing happens
with like like Far Cry 2 was made like
it was famous for its fire propagation
and how like realistic the spread of
fire was and how like the flamethrower
was one of the best weapons in that game
and how you can just set fire to a patch
of grass and then the entire field would
end up ablaze with all the trees on fire
and it was amazing it looked awesome but
it was also really useful from a
gameplay perspective in like you can you
can destroy entire camps that way you
can also do that accidentally if you
fire a rocket launcher the back drafts
from that will set on fire the grass
behind you if you're on a hill it's so
much of Far Cry 2 has like amazing
attention to detail in its gunplay and
that makes it so much more satisfying to
play it feels like it feels like they've
really thought about it rather than just
being like there's a lot of guns I
respect that and I'm about to drop a
mixtape and after that I'm gonna be
known for fire propagation next topic is
progression so it's worth clarifying
here there's two types of progressions
we could be potentially talking about
the story progression or character
progression for me like character
progression is what I think is more
impactful in Far Cry 5 especially it's
kind of like the it's different from the
previous Far Cry game is the more recent
like 3 & 4 and that that was a lot of
tied to like forcing you down certain
paths and what I didn't like about it
what I like about Far Cry 5 let's say is
that it's fairly simple it's all about
earning perks and then putting them into
abilities it ties those to like small
mini achievements or challenges I play
primarily stealth so when I started
playing it was a lot of like bow kills
and stealth kills and once I kind of
like run out of perks that I could earn
from that play style it's time to move
on to do something more drastic and do
use these adopter different other play
styles so then I went into like machine
gun kill
grenade kills so what I like about the
progression in Far Cry 5 is it kind of
if fun was you into different playstyles
and it funnels you into different
experiences without actually forcing you
with missions all manner of it wants you
to see everything and explore everything
and it uses the upgrade system to do
that which i think is really clever and
enjoyable I think a lot of that is
definitely true and a far cry 2 does a
lot of the same things but I think far
cry 2 does it in a much more natural way
my problem with far cry 5 is that it's
also artificial whereas with far cry 2
it's way more natural and realistic it's
just like you can't get this gun yet
because it's way too expensive so you
have to go out there and earn the money
to get that gun and then later on in the
game much later you can buy that gun
which will completely change your
playstyle
I think a really important part of
progression in Far Cry is how you learn
the environment and getting to know the
places that you'll go to and in Far Cry
5 you can just fast travel everywhere so
you never get to learn the map really
you just you you ping yourself there and
you're peeing yourself there in your
pants up there and then that's sort of
you know you never feel like you're a
part of that environment whereas in Far
Cry 2 there is fast travel but only in
for points on the map so you end up
actually moving there yourself and then
you find yourself actually learning your
environment and so not only is your
character progressing but you are
progressing in that world as well as a
player and you get to learn your
environment by traveling within it
that's exactly what Far Cry 5 does but
it just never forces that upon you it
gives you the option so you you're if
you're just Foss traveling from point to
point usually it means that you're just
hitting their main missions so the game
kind of subtly tells you hey you might
want to wander around and when you start
wandering around it has all these cool
scenarios that are just in the world so
you do build that awareness of the world
and you figure it out and what I like
about it is it kind of gives you it
separates me the areas into it like
manageable chunks so the thing that you
were saying about guns and for being
forced to buy them at a later stage
that's that's an interesting way and I
agree that it's natural but it makes it
makes it harder for certain people like
I can play a first-person issue a bunch
of different ways my preferred way is to
go stealth if I can what I love about
Far Cry 5 is from the outset it's like
here's all the tools that you can that
you need to play in any number of styles
and it's a style that another game that
I'm gonna mention Metal Gear Solid 5
great game that's what it does it does a
similar thing right it's like here's a
pun
two things for you to use it slightly
give me the options to play how I won
and let me have that fun instead of
getting it right at the end when I'm
kind of done with a game I might not
even make it to that point what if I
never get to the point where I can play
how I want to play that's not an ideal
experience surely that's something to
aim for you want to get there so that
you could anyone okay I think I'm done
by then like I want to play sounds like
you're already done with Far Cry five
and you just wanna play Metal Gear Solid
5 ABS dust 100 percent of the time that
is the case any game if you put
half-life 3 in front of me right now I
play for an hour and then play male your
solid fives and let's cut time off
before he bangs on about Metal Gear
Solid 5 for the next hour let us know
your thoughts on who you think won the
debate by voting in the above poll or if
you're over on GameSpot calm by putting
your thoughts in the comment section
below
it'll be your votes that decide who wins
so make yourselves hurt right time for
this week's dose of stupidity with our
quickfire round a series of dumb
questions written by the rest of the UK
team let's see how Tom and Oscar get on
who would your game vote for in the
presidential election it's quite clear
whom I wanna would vote for so to
paraphrase Oscar from the first episode
of vs. this doesn't represent me
Ubisoft serve use as a whole the
development teams of the whole far cry 5
would probably vote Trump
it likes billion billions and billions
and billions and billions and billions
and billions and billions and billions
describe your games perfect bait far cry
- you'd go on Safari
you'd have a nice romantic sunset
looking at some zebras and some lions
and some Tigers and then you've probably
both contract malaria together and end
up in heaven dead together on the side
of the road killed by the jackal would
you rather get mauled by a 100
cheeseburger size Bears or one
regular-sized bear called cheeseburger
so that like it's probably worth saying
like you're getting mauled either way
here regardless if I'm gonna go I want
it I want to go in a novel way because
like then someone reports it on the news
as like as a guy got killed by one file
cheeseburgers bears do they then go on a
rampage like killing all of your family
and like your friends let's leave my
family out there
do your best southern drawl I can't even
remember what kind of Southern drawl
goddamnit two more I'm gonna go home and
play some video games I'm gonna play Far
Cry 4 5 daddy when can I get my room
back Booey
all right that's going remember to make
your voice heard in our poll or in the
comment section below and tell us who
you think argued their case better if
you enjoyed this episode of vs. make
sure to hit that subscribe button as
we'll have new episodes of the show
every Wednesday thanks for watching see
ya
[Music]
you